[Music]
hello everybody
my name is rob riche and i'm a professor
of political science at stanford
university
this year is like no other we've
experienced as americans
a raging pandemic social unrest deep
economic uncertainty documented threats
of external interference in our election
and all as this election year is already
well underway due to many factors
including our complex
entangled relationship with technology
we have reached the point
of needing to stand up for democracy
itself
and for the 240 year long experiment of
democracy in the united states
in ways that we couldn't have imagined
just a few decades ago
we are going to use the experience of
this class to raise awareness
of all of these critical issues based
upon material from a course on this
subject being run with my colleagues
at stanford continuing studies join me
and my co-instructor marica shaka
in this free class that will help you
understand the
unprecedented influence of technology
and technology policy on america's
elections
and democratic process we will take a
close look at how a public sphere
plagued by polarization online filter
bubbles echo chambers political
advertising and much more
impacts our ability to be well-informed
citizens
join us to be more than just a voter
become an advocate for a better
democracy
you